hey Doug Walker here announcing a few
cons that I'm going to coming up this
month
the first one is indy popcon and that is
june 17th to the 19th and it isn't just
me it's my brother Rob it's Malcolm it's
Tamra there's a lot of good people at
this con I think John Bailey is there
Kevin Smith's gonna be there just tons
and tons of good people with a guest
list you'll be like holy crap are these
cool people so definitely go it's an
indie appleís Indiana and just all sorts
of great folks so definitely go check
that out and the next one is too many
games as in Oaks Pennsylvania is June
24th to the 26 I'm gonna be there James
Rolfe is gonna be there uncle yo is
gonna be there all sorts of again just
great people this is a kind of been
around for a long time and if you're
gonna get tickets to that go ahead look
in the link below there should be a I
guess like a tracking code or something
like that I guess they want like monitor
which guests bring in like the most
people that like give tickets so I did
show by a fansite so what they asked for
so if you're gonna go get to gets
definitely use that link with indy
popcon just go on their website and
check it out but yeah you can definitely
go to those links Oh Jim a games that is
a June 24 to the 26 those are two June
cons coming up that you can get a chance
to see me you can talk to me I love
meeting fans I love making conversation
and stuff so hopefully you guys will be
there I'd love to see you and that's
about it hopefully I will see you there
later